here's a brief reenactment of when I
first learned about this Means War
hmm ooh Tom Hardy is in it Wow who's the
directed by Mick G Oh
[Music]
This Means War is directed by Mick G the
guy who brought us both Charlie's Angels
films we are Marshall and Terminator
Salvation it stars Tom Hardy Chris Pine
Reese Witherspoon and Chelsea Handler
it's about these two CIA agents and they
both start dating the same girl by
accident they were not aware they were
both trying to date Reese Witherspoon
Reese Witherspoon has her best friend
Chelsea Handler and she's constantly
asking her for advice like which one do
I pick obviously she knows she's dating
two guys but she doesn't know they know
each other and it becomes a giant
competition for both of these guys they
start using their gadgets and stuff to
spy on her to figure out what she likes
they both try to get ahead of each other
in all different types of ways and it's
supposed to be like a fun action-packed
romantic comedy this is one of the most
disappointing movies I've seen in a
while this was awful I'm serious this
movie was terrible now hear me out cuz
I'm gonna explain this I love Tom Rd and
that's why I was looking forward this
movie I really love that guy and he was
great in this movie I thought that he
was by far the best part of this movie
Chris Pine was just Chris Pine again he
was Kirk all over again he plays a
douchebag jock who sleeps with every
girl that he can possibly find he plays
his character and everything he's always
some cocky guy in every movie play a
different character please what is so
awful about this movie is the writing it
is honestly like a five-year-old kid
took a cran came up with this plot just
like I like to write movies I want to
write this means war two guys fight over
a girl it's going to be great
hey mommy bring me my chocolate milk we
should have a scene worth explosions and
we'll get one of those guys to direct it
who can't really film action we should
have a scene where they can bring me my
chocolate milk I'm not even kidding the
writing in this movie
absolutely god-awful it's difficult for
me to express fully how awful this movie
is without spoiling some points if you
want to watch this Means War you might
not want to finish this review but I
encourage you please do not see it it is
so bad here's a little bit of a spoiler
Tom Hardy and Chris Pine eventually meet
in front of Reese Witherspoon and she
finds out that oh I guess you guys know
each other which causes her to get very
upset to back up into a corner go I
trusted you trusted you and she runs
away like crying I'm thinking to myself
wait a second are we actually supposed
to feel sorry for you you two-timing
whore who knowingly dated two guys at
once cheating on both of them and then
eventually decides you know what I can't
decide which one's the best I'm going to
decide which one is the best in bed and
I'll pick that one based on how good
they are at sex that honestly is what
she does how in the world am I supposed
to feel sorry for that girl she is by
far the worst person in this movie in
regards to morals she knowingly cheats
on both of her guys then decides to
figure out which one of them is best by
sex who does that
Chris Pine and Tom Hardy both lie and
cheat to get to this girl and Chelsea
Handler encourages reason blue spoon the
whole time there is not one good person
in this movie now I haven't even gotten
to the main villain of the film a
terrorist who has nothing to do with the
plot other than to be a terrorist that
they talk about briefly all of a sudden
he shows up at the end and kidnaps Reese
Witherspoon and now they have to go save
her which fixes everything of course
seriously there is the cliched terrorist
guy he goes like oh haha and stuff like
throughout the whole movie it's so
terrible I was like what is going on in
this movie who wrote this I started
thinking there has to be something here
some problem with the production
something there must be something that
went wrong here sure enough I looked it
up this film was shot in 2010 it was
from a script that was floating around
in Hollywood for a long time and Mick G
finally snatched it up did some rewrites
on it the action is incomprehensibly
filmed the dialogue is just absolutely
cheesy and awful there's nothing about
the movie that makes sense
character motivations are completely out
the window but my biggest problem with
this movie honestly is the finale and
like I said spoiler alert she picks
Chris Pine out of town
Hardy and then all of a sudden Tom
Hardy's ex-wife comes out of nowhere and
says I want to start over again with you
and just so we can have Tom Hardy have
like a nice little payoff of some girl
from his past
now seriously Tom Hardy is the first guy
to date Reese Witherspoon the very first
guy to date her Chris Pine meets her at
a music store and literally stalks her
to her job ruins her entire job
presentation in front of a whole bunch
of people to force her to go on a date
with him he's like the d-bag a-hole
throughout the entire movie and she
actually picks him over Tom Hardy who
was a good man from the start the
characters in this movie are so stupid
and poorly written there's also a scene
where somehow Tom Hardy sneaks into a
circus tent and starts swinging on the
trapeze with Reese Witherspoon I'm not
kidding that's in the movie there were a
few good things about it other than the
charms of Tom Hardy to be honest just a
terrible terrible terrible movie
honestly though audiences will enjoy
this movie I guarantee it audiences will
go to this movie leave and be satisfied
and think they just saw the best movie
they'd ever seen in their entire life
it's just one of those movies where
teenage girls they see it and they go to
school the next day and they're like oh
my god Jenn that was the best movie I
have ever seen ever seen it's just one
of those movies I'm gonna give this
Means War addy I'd like to know what's
your favorite movie that balances
romance and action some of them are so
bad but then they got some good ones
there's some good ones in there can you
think of one can you think of what it's
so horrible if you liked this review you
can subscribe to my channel and get
stuck by niced
[Music]